in geneva where president biden's
historic meeting with russian president
vladimir putin is happening
right now here you can see the two men
shaking hands just a short time ago
it is mr biden's first meeting with the
russian leader
as president he's promised a much
tougher stance than his predecessor
donald trump
who appeared to have a cozier
relationship with mr putin the topics on
the agenda
are expected to include nuclear arms
control
russian-linked cyber attacks on the u.s
and the imprisonment of russian
opposition leader
alexei navalny our chief white house
correspondent nancy cordes is traveling
with president biden
and joins us from geneva nancy good
morning we saw a brief glimpse
from the press pool a little while ago
of the two leaders sitting down together
i believe mr biden was heard to tell mr
putin that it's always better
to meet face to face do we have any idea
what else
they discussed in that moment the press
was allowed in
well president biden anthony was also
asked whether he
trusts putin and putin was asked whether
he trusts president biden
president biden nodded but to be honest
it was difficult to make out what was
said because
so many u.s reporters in the traveling
white house pool were actually
boxed out of that room because a swarm
of russian journalists far more than
were supposed
to be there boxed them out got into the
room and there was actually a physical
altercation between the russians and the
americans
this is the kind of chaos that often
does accompany the russian leader
sometimes it's meant to throw the
americans or whoever he's meeting with
off their game but nevertheless all of
the reporters have now been pulled from
the room
and that meeting is taking place first a
small meeting between
presidents biden and putin and their top
foreign aids
and then after about an hour and a half
or so we expect it to open up
and four more aides on each side will be
allowed into the room
nancy how did how did president biden
prepare for this meeting
well he spent weeks sitting down with
his secretary of state
his national security advisor here in
europe he's been on the road for the
past week he's been meeting with
various european leaders getting their
take on what they want him to bring up
what they think
is not as important their experiences
meeting with the russians
so he has been preparing meticulously
over the past few weeks and as his
white house press secretary said
recently in some ways he's been
preparing for this
for 50 years because he has such a long
history
of meeting with russian leaders and
we're expecting nancy this meeting could
go on for
for literally four or five hours or more
that's the best indication we have from
both the white house
and the russians but uh these are two
men
who have the gift of gab who have a lot
of
agenda items to to get through so it's
quite possible
that this meeting could go longer and
then of course we've got press
conferences
after that those could take a couple of
hours to get through as well
yeah and an attempt here to reset an
agenda between these two countries
in a relationship that as we've been
saying all morning is at a low point
at this point nancy thank you very much